kick that horse lee
this show the church of what's happening
now is presented by on it
this show
is brought to you by
zip recruiter
ziprecruiter allows you to post your job
on all of the top to 200 of the plus job
sites including social media
go to zip recruiter.com church right now
to post your jobs for free
ziprecruiter.com
church
this show is also brought to you by
meundies go to meundies.com
joey right now to get 20 off of your
first order plus shipping is always free
in the us and canada that's meundies.com
joey
this show is also brought to you by
helix sleep
helix sleep
makes is where you can buy mattresses
online customized for you for hundreds
of dollars instead of thousands
go to helixsleep.com
joey and get 50 off of your order that's
helixsleep.com
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
the first real monday of the
[ __ ] year
complete
the first real monday of the
[ __ ] year
the church of what's happening now
[ __ ] little motley crew getting the
party started
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
moves like a cat are you kidding me or
what
lee syed
my little
jewish flying friend
and my main man
professor joey alvarado
dropping in to start the year off on the
right [ __ ] foot here we go
that's right here we go
pick that mule blow up the speakers i
want the computer to blow up [ __ ] apple
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
you're here
you made it another beautiful [ __ ]
weekend that arrived it went and that's
it the [ __ ] done the armenian
christmas is over the cuban christmas is
over on the seventh any [ __ ] other
three kings that are gonna show up
showed up yesterday all right so that's
it it's over put the tree away
stop talking about the [ __ ] you got for
christmas
2017's here looking you straight in the
eye and what do you want to do you want
to dick around again another [ __ ]
year [ __ ] that [ __ ] they ain't gonna
[ __ ] around this year trump's gonna take
over and tighten the seat belt [ __ ]
if you ain't stealing you better
start if you didn't get that gun yet you
better [ __ ] get it you better get bbs
or scope
the whole [ __ ] thing
because you know what trump's gonna do
he's gonna move immigrants into your
house
[ __ ] airbnb they got all your airbnb
addresses they're going to start moving
immigrants to your house and give you 60
a day see how much you like yeah airbnb
what's up lee
i'm doing really good man that was fun
today yeah birthday party
you know we got some kids from school we
got some kids we know
we my wife you know my wife is a gentile
so she believes the weather man the
weatherman can suck your dick listen
when you wake up in the morning that's
the weather i don't believe nothing if
they tell you six inches it's two inches
if they tell you a big storm and the
levee's gonna break don't believe
nothing they said there was gonna be two
stuff two storms johnny whatever maybe
on nbc you're gonna be another storm and
the other stuff when they picked us up
for the calusa casino friday it goes
listen i don't even know if you guys are
getting out tomorrow because this road
is going to [ __ ] be flooded the next
day we were [ __ ] nothing nothing
happened
a plane they didn't serve as cocktails
or soda because you can't predict mother
nature man but listen don't believe [ __ ]
till is [ __ ] they said sunday it was
going to be dead and saturday
how nice was it today it was beautiful
[ __ ] beautiful beautiful day to be
alive it was my daughter's fourth
birthday it was tough in the morning
once i got her there it was easy the
pain went away i couldn't believe she
was [ __ ] turning four wow
damn joey my wife was very happy my wife
made cupcakes and [ __ ] dressed up the
tables with felicia michaels they went
there at 10 in the morning and me and my
daughter watched the end of rambo first
blood yeah we watched [ __ ] the
beginning of rocky together she was
watching
rocky one the bible the bible there's
only one story better than rocky my
cousin's in the that rocky movie the
first one yeah i had eddie animal lopez
he was like from big hazard in um
in highland park he he fought spanx for
the heavyweight belt his name is eddie
the amber lopez um what part he's the
part where where rocky went back and he
was cleaning up the gym yeah and then he
was picking up that spit bucket and that
guy was talking [ __ ] to him in the ring
that's my cousin eddie
yeah he was big he was even in a movie
with barbara streisand and ryan o'neill
called the main event did you ever main
event yeah i know you're i think old
school old school oh he's in that movie
too yeah you know rocky is one of those
movies that you've seen 20 times
more than 20 times tnt is on the game's
a blowout
and you're scrolling and you get to it
and anytime you get to rocky
it's just a great part
it's just a great part the night before
i call lee and i go liam i'm watching
rambo
now in 1984 professor i went off the
deep end right
so on 85 i had to move
and lay low
so i had this route i lived in like uh
bergen county jersey i would take a bus
to fort lee
and i was so poor i had money for the
essentials
i was so poor that i'd saved the four
hours and i'd walk over the george
washington bridge
i'd walk over and i'd get cuban food
by the hospital and then i'd walk two
blocks to get a nickel bag of weed i'd
roll a joint and i'd smoke it on the
walk nobody said dick to you without a
license with a license that was harlem
jack i'd walk smoking the joint like
going to a movie theater because i
killed time till five o'clock
and i saw
there was two movie theaters there was
100
this had to be 181 178 if anybody knows
tweet me tomorrow when you listen
this movie theater was on the corner of
broadway and right there in
washington heights but there was one
that was down the block that one was a
two for two dollar type
where the floors were sticky every once
in a while they did porno once a month
and people would jerk off and [ __ ]
but it was next to a carvel so i'd get
ice cream and go in there and i seen
like
office and a gentleman and uh that's a
great movie yeah and uh
and uh american gigolo
i saw a stephen bauer double feature
there i saw scarface the other one was
like a double richard yeah it was that's
what they do they show like dirty harry
yeah and that one for two bucks but up
the corner
they showed or you know the movies that
came out the ones that you wanted to see
that came out friday now professor i
don't know if you still remember when
rambo two came out rambo first blood
ramble two was when he went to vietnam
of course right that's the one where
they electrocuted him yeah you guys
talking shitty russian and he's the same
guy that's in beverly hills cops
right now he's a russian and [ __ ] do you
complain
i bought the mission all that [ __ ]
let me tell you something so
i haven't i hadn't seen rambo the first
one and it's on and i got a few hours to
kill till five o'clock
but when i walk in i realize holy [ __ ]
this is a black movie theater
oh wow so i sit down you know me i don't
give a [ __ ] what's happening brother you
know man
i sit down
i watch the [ __ ] movie let me tell
you something
all black people have a white quirk
like i had a friend that was a [ __ ] but
he was an adam sandler fan
and then i had another friend that was
straight up gangster afro black power
but don't you be talking no [ __ ] about
who what did he like
who the [ __ ] did he like the beatles oh
wow the beatles blacker than black soul
music soul power honkies but man the
[ __ ] beatles of the [ __ ]
uh do you think i'm a lot of black
people's guilty white guilty pleasure
like that yeah that's where i am
[ __ ] wrong
i guess so i've seen black people go
crazy in movie theaters because i lived
in new york city so i catch black movies
i loved it
but i never saw black people go as crazy
as when rambo
they like rambo oh first blood part two
when he's in the mud
and he opens up his eyes and he comes
out with the knife and he stabs the
white dude
black people went bananas but where
black people lost their mind was when he
takes the arrow with the grenade yeah
yeah and he loads it up against the
vietnamese dude and the dude is shooting
at him and he ain't flinching he's got a
grenade and he [ __ ] launches it when
that grenade hit that chinese do them
warm up
people nearly had a [ __ ] heart attack
in the movie theater i loved it i
i turned around it was [ __ ] beautiful
oh man black people loved john rambo and
it made me watching that movie made me
realize something [ __ ] at that time
sylvester stallone was a huge star oh my
god jesus [ __ ] christ he was he was
huge when the rambo two came out
that was june of 85
that
packed movie theaters across the [ __ ]
world jack
and all his movies were themed american
like even rocky i was watching the rock
i watched i watched rocky today takes
the girl home and they make out and they
fall on the floor by the way the best
line than the american-made movie in the
last 40 years when he goes rock i hear
she's [ __ ] he goes she ain't retired
he's just a little shy
that movie has
if you're going to shoot a movie dog
please watch rocky before you shoot your
stupid [ __ ] movie didn't he write he
wrote he wrote directed it did that
[ __ ] sold his dog
you know gave away his dog [ __ ]
that that they had no extras today steve
simone said they had no extras in the
ice people talk about that [ __ ]
goodfellas scene but when they were ice
skating professor
whoever shot that
they weren't [ __ ] around he's talking
about southpaw you know where southpaw
came from his elbow was pointing south
south jersey south canton southpaw you
know like he's talking to but the best
scene is when he goes to knock on the
door
he knocks before he knocks on the door
he looks apart he goes oh hey
and he goes like this like he's going to
box the door and then he goes up against
the tunnel because i've never talked to
a door before
i feel kind of stupid and he's like
paulie's like talk to her and he's like
okay it's a [ __ ] door that's all
comedy that people don't know about
today that you don't need to write
i went to a meeting a few weeks ago and
i told to do it i go you know what
comedy is man
when joe pesci and de niro are sitting
at the table with joe pesci's mother and
you got a body in the trunk and you're
eating
and you're hanging out like it's nothing
but you got a [ __ ] body in the trunk
and then that is you take a knife from
your mother
to cut the guy to finish him off
that's real comedy like to me that that
made me laugh that's like natural who
the [ __ ] thought of that [ __ ]
yeah that's chemistry man they had good
chemistry between one another lee look
at the shape of you you haven't oh yeah
i'm already going through changes you
ever look at panic on your face changes
what's happening professor
starting up the year with a new [ __ ]
dvd
i still download it i see you there
every [ __ ] day putting you a little
six for 5 30 in the morning when i wake
up you already have posted up the you do
facebook live and you get people
watching and it's pretty [ __ ]
interesting when i came from cuba all i
remember is a child that
nine o'clock on abc or one of those
channels you have to look it up what's
his name came on every morning
and in those days
50 of people ran with that [ __ ]
who's the dude
no the dude before
the dude who invented the richard
who
do before richard simmons he just died
when i was a kid jacqueline was on fire
he's the [ __ ] man dude he was the
[ __ ] he was the [ __ ] man
the news and nine o'clock it's jack
o'lane and he [ __ ] did exercises with
you and then he made a protein shake
with you he had so he had a gym out here
too
he had gyms all over the country that
was but he wouldn't hang out in there
yeah they were all over the country my
mom said she used to work out the win
over here somewhere i don't know where
back in the day so right now with the
with new technology a person like
yourself could get a gopro put it in
front of [ __ ] alberto's thing totally
at 5 30 in the morning if you're broke
and that's what half the people that are
selling selling digital downloads that's
what they do you could just use your
cell phone
nowadays you know but like actually i
have like
in burbank you know we have a lot of
people that work in the industry and one
of my students michael he's a camera
operator so that guy brought in like all
my [ __ ] is like legit like with the same
stuff he uses on the set on disney
movies and everything he brought in
there he brought the lavalier
he had his little camera on his shoulder
he had the other camera i mean it was
legit so it's not something that i just
whipped up on my
my
galaxy note
i was actually considering it until you
offered i was like man like how am i
gonna film this next project you know
because it's not it's not cheap hiring a
professional cameraman you know or
camera operator that's what they call
them
you know it's crazy that
when rogan found out i was at albertos
he came to me and he goes how's this guy
he's [ __ ] great that guy he knows
what he's doing like oh i know he does
the kettlebells
but i've never been to him i know he's a
great teacher he teaches the
fundamentals class
and that's when i got turned on to your
kettlebell thing
and i watch it i don't think i can make
a class i think i wouldn't be able to
walk for four days oh man i do five sets
of do you think i'm gonna kill you joey
i do five sets of cleans i do five sets
of swings maybe six i do some squats the
way you do with your arms like this i do
a couple of those i tried doing that
much see that's the thing that's a
misconception people have like a lot
like there's a you know we have a
shitload of students at legacy man and
some of the girls in the tough girl boot
camp they're like oh we want to try your
class but we're like we're afraid i'm
like what do you guys think i'm gonna do
like kill you i adapt to workouts for
everybody man because like i have my
regulars that come and they're pretty
advanced but then i have people that pop
in just for the first time too so i'm
watching everybody i'm watching with you
about adapting exercises for you
i'm telling you that you're allowed to
take breaks some people you know they
push you and push you and push you but i
mean if you do that you traumatize
people and you scare them you know i'm
not there to do that like i want to keep
you i'm not trying to scare you away so
i never push anybody harder than they
need to be pushed you know you know your
body bet better than i do
so i'm always asking hey how do you feel
you want to take a break take a break
it's okay don't try to keep up with
everybody yeah but you know
what a [ __ ] great combination
5 30 kettlebells and then 6 30.
you get out of that 7 30 you wash your
[ __ ]
you have a [ __ ] protein shake and you
go to work and you're like in your case
you you wash your [ __ ] and your bidet
yeah your affordable day my little
portable day but it's [ __ ] crazy
you know before i got locked up
professor
uh the ups guy at hertz
was this dude that looked like [ __ ]
tarzan
and i asked him what's up with long hair
and was he no no no short hair white
dude good [ __ ] solid white dude
i would talk to him every day about
different [ __ ] when i go i gotta ask you
something because at that time i was in
good shape i knew it was gonna get
locked up
so i was in tip-top shape my running
condition i rode the bicycle to [ __ ]
hurts
you know i was 25
and i asked him he goes i swim
and i go do you teach he goes no i go to
this group class professor it was at 6
30 and 7 30. but he goes go to 6 30
because she'll have more time to work
with you a swimming class oh my god
professor it was called master swimming
program wow now swimming is no joke man
no no professor she hadn't
set everybody in she was a
hawaiian chick that did that [ __ ]
thing in hawaii what thing in hawaii the
thing with it you gotta swim and you
gotta ride the bike and you gotta run
the iron man oh the iron competition
yeah so that's just
something that's what she did
so the people that were in that pool
were triathletes so you go in there
she'd go she'd go up to a blackboard or
she'd be yelling with a whistle and
she'd go least i had
give me four 40s and 60 seconds pulling
give me another 440 and
53 seconds kicking
and then put it all together and give me
four 40s in 60 seconds with a minute
interval of breathing
and that was your workout for the day
yeah yeah yeah so it would be 40 would
be one way
so four forties four times four forties
that's right you just murdered what
would you do oh my god the first time i
jumped in the porsche jump in the pool
let me see you swim and i did a bunch of
things and i was moving like a gorilla
and i looked up and i was hitting the
wall and said yeah i'm gonna work
together from scratch and the first
three classes she just made me hold the
wall and kick yeah the problem is you're
you're moving like a gorilla gorilla in
the water right there like a girl no no
who the [ __ ] who knows how to swim
legitimately it's like uh when we went
away to vegas and i went to the gym and
i'm on the gym getting warmed up and i
look at my friend's girlfriend i didn't
even know it was my friend's girlfriend
but i look at her
and the reason why i looked at it i'm
not because she was attractive i looked
at it because her running form
was perfect
you know her and for people to see that
she was born and raised in russia they
teach you how to run in russia correctly
as a child
and i've always i told rogan on the
podcast and i told her i was telling lee
that when you first get to joe namath
football camp
the first thing they do after you eat is
before you eat is they run you into 40
and they write it down and then on
monday
through friday before you put pads on or
a helmet they teach you how to run
correctly and on friday before you get
on the bus they go run a 40
and also they show it to you and they go
you beat your speed by this much and
you're like i didn't come in here faster
no they show you how to run
nice you know it's like when you do it
with a guy like me you go joey slow down
once you pass this guard rest for a
minute
watch his arm you know there's little
breathers
as you move along that you learn
the same thing is it running
the same thing we were talking one time
in the podcast about pitching if you i
guarantee you're a big strong guy and i
come up to you and go pitch in front of
the guy from the just like major league
yeah he throws 95 but he got no control
but if i teach him a little control
maybe he could pitch 90 but he could
pitch with control
i will teach you how to pitch
effectively
the technique the technique behind the
contributing effective yes
follow-through and all that stuff and
that's what always kind of that's why
whenever i
i keep my kettlebell movements real easy
like the one movement you do between the
legs i tried that and i understand you
know
i figure right yeah it really affects
because like you know like a lot of one
of the things people do is they see the
videos that i post and stuff like that
and they just try it
those videos aren't really meant to be
instructions i'm just showing you guys
like what i do over there but like the
instructionals that's different you need
you need to go to the gym and learn
how to do it and how i work how i they
don't see how i work up to those
exercises you know what i mean because i
do nothing but body weight first and i'm
doing a lot of times we're doing the
bodyweight movement before we even do it
apply it to a kettlebell you know what i
mean that way you you you practice the
mechanics first and warm your body up
first before you even touch a kettlebell
because like i don't like i don't touch
a kettlebell until i'm thoroughly warm
there's a lot of ego involved with
weight lifting like just even i don't
care about lifting even with myself just
because
i i don't want like i'm like oh i don't
want to do a 16 i want to do a 20
kilogram but i also don't want to throw
my back out no you don't don't so like
it's
it's hard it's a hard it's a hard
balance to like to increase your weight
because you don't want to get personally
like but yeah yeah i don't care how much
weight you live you can live it doesn't
mean that you're strong
like people that do a real heavy one
turkish get up right and like like who
cares you know like try doing an
alternating turkish get up for two
minutes straight
that's a little bit more oh my god
practical jesus you know you're gonna
burn more fat you're gonna work more
muscles you know and you're not gonna
hurt yourself let me ask you something
let's go for it let's pretend you're a
big guy like me right and you really
want to use
the kettlebell for cardio for weight
loss
shouldn't it be like weightlifting where
i want to get stronger and put on weight
so i'm gonna do 300 pound deadlifts
now that i want to not i feel a lot
better that i eliminated that 45 pound
kettlebell from my life
i eliminated that one it just wasn't
i was i was walking around sore
for no reason
i started working out with a 35 and i
feel a lot better professor yeah i had
it bent over rows i added curls
at the end to really sweat it up a
little bit i got a bag i hit the bag i
jump a little rope
i don't do nothing no more when i when i
because the first place i went to for
kettlebells where lee went to
it's the russian you open up with
[ __ ] 140 pound deadlifts that's crazy
and then we would do swings
and there was really no cardio
you were walking around
yeah see like the way i do it is you're
gonna work your whole body
in that one
hour workout you're gonna work all your
muscles all your major muscle groups
you're gonna do your pushing you're
pulling you're squatting your hinge and
everything so when you're hitting all
your muscles at once your heart rate
shoots up and you start burning fat a
lot faster as opposed to like lifting
like a bodybuilder does a bodybuilder is
going to do us they always do like split
workouts where they'll do like chest and
back one day
you know what i mean so there's no
cardio involved they do their cardio
like by running or whatever like that
but
in my class man you can burn up to like
600 calories in one in one one hour easy
because you just work your whole body i
i use like different protocols and um i
have something i call anaerobic pyramid
conditioning and aerobic is just you
know it's like doing a sprint as opposed
to going for a jog you know what i mean
that's how i structure my workouts just
like fighting like jiu jitsu right
one minute you're like scrambling around
trying to pass somebody's guard and then
next minute you're kind of chilling for
a second and then you're doing it again
you're doing like a full body movement
at once and then you're breaking so
that's how i structure the workouts just
kind of like fighting
hence the word kettle jitsu but yeah but
it sounds like you're doing good but
like it always helps to have somebody
like me to help show you how to use it
properly because that's what i do you
know you you might be missing a few
things you know
i'm really excited just to i'm gonna
because i'm gonna get your download
because i love kettlebells
but i've noticed a huge difference and i
told joey even even before my place
closed he was like why don't you just
because it wasn't inexpensive he's like
why don't you just get some and just do
it i'm like there's a there's a
difference for me with having someone
tell me what to do like going to a class
or even watching something like this
versus having me be being self-motivated
during the workout
you like you work out as a person but
you're also a teacher like
like how do you deal with that and you
know like that is my motivation teaching
i love i love teaching so like
the fact that somebody will come spend
an hour with me during that day i take
it very seriously and i i just
that that's what keeps me voted
motivated to keep continuously growing
as a kettlebell trainer and a jiu jitsu
trainer you know i strive to be that's
man that's all i really do that's all i
obsess about is jujitsu and kettlebells
is pretty sad and hanging out with my my
dog you know but um
that keeps me motivated and just the
fact that i really love kettlebell
training man i mean when i once i found
that i was like that was it you know i
didn't need any other
workout tools you know you got people
swinging clubs and
those mace bells and stuff like that you
know that's all
weights for you no i don't bench presses
nothing i do body weight and kettlebell
i don't do pull-ups
i only do rolling
rowing for my back and stuff like that
because the way i look at it is um
i don't do anything that resembles
pulling up from this angle you know i
don't do any if i was a rock climber or
something maybe i would do pull-ups but
all if you notice in jiu-jitsu we're
always pulling we're always pulling from
here
we're not pulling like this
plus it's kind of hard to incorporate
chin ups and stuff into like big group
classes and you know i'm teaching like
15 20 people at a time you know so like
for me kettlebell is like i don't know
you know if you know who steve maxwell
is steve maxwell has been on joe rogan's
podcast a few times he has a saying that
with kettlebells you get the most bang
for your buck
like your gym is right there your body
is your gym and that kettlebell is just
it's plenty and it does me good man you
know
i've used it at like a world-class level
you know
and my all the tournaments that i
compete in i do productive pretty good
you know and people doing crossfit you
know
and you know
it works for me i love it i never get
tired of it and i'm constantly
constantly like evolving and creating
more routines and different movements
and stuff like that i learn from
everybody i learn from my students all
the time
the only question i have because
only one question
one question
you would think
you would you know it would work arms
and you know it works like your hips and
and i know cause you i you can feel it
in your legs
but is that would be my only
uh argument i guess against only doing
kettlebells versus other weights because
other ways you can maybe do leg workouts
but
do kettlebells specifically like how do
they work leg muscles how do they work
because i know they do because i feel
them in mostly my so my like thighs not
not so much my i never really got so
much of my calves are they good in cows
you could use a kettlebell to do
anything like i mean if you wanted to
work your calves you could just grab a
kettlebell right here and just do calf
raises you know what i mean oh and
anything you do with a kettlebell
excuse me anything you do at barbell or
dumbbells you can do with a kettlebell
in most cases you could even do it
better because they just fit with your
body a lot easier you can rack them and
you can do it one-handed rack kettlebell
you could do double grass you could do a
goblet position it's just
they're just so versatile man but like
any way you you work your legs with uh
barbells or dumbbells you can do the
same thing with kettlebells you can do
lunch you could hold a kettlebell here
and do lunges you could do lateral
lunges you could do squats you could do
jump split squats you could do all kinds
of stuff man
and we a lot of that stuff is in um in
that kb strength program too so i'll
just send me your email and i'll send
you the download link man
dig it thank you i'm very impressed with
the kettlebell i know
i love the workout like i said if i'm
the only reason how easy is it for you
just to have one at home just work at a
home like that i have a 25 30. i'm doing
that with a barbecue
and if i can't do what i got to do i
just sit back there today i went back to
4 30 and i walked out of there at 10 to
6.
i drank a little protein after drink i
washed my little monkey
i came out i had a little pasta a little
salad and i came here that's it an
edible
and that's it you know i don't like
i was doing this big time how i lost
when i first walked into macafolli i was
418 pounds wow i had to put on two pair
of shorts because i'd always pee myself
while i was breathing
and he was just hitting mitch with me
that's it and he goes listen you keep
coming in i could take all this money
from you
40 bucks an hour he was charging me that
wasn't a lot of money he was great he
was from boston
he goes i just want you to join the gym
and come in here every day and hit the
bag for a half hour just want you to
stand in front of the gym don't leave
you until there's a puddle under you
i thought it was the simplest thing i
ever heard the first time i went there i
tapped out like 11 minutes
i was like i can't do this and he just
wanted you to stay stationary and just
hit the bag but do it like in a mild
horse dance and not to let your legs
become
why would he say it
don't let your legs go into the mud
don't don't i don't want your feet in
one place pick them up one time pivot a
little bit and he'd go do five minutes
ten minutes five minutes ten minutes
that's how i lost the weight in the
beginning i didn't want to lose well i
didn't want to lift weights he goes i
don't want you looking good hit the bag
and do the bicycle that was smart
because he was just telling you to do
like low impact stuff that's not going
to hurt you because like
at 400 pounds there's not too many
things you can do no i was going at
night so nobody would sleep around and
doing deck squats and turkish get-ups
and [ __ ] at that weight but like that's
smart you know he had you doing some
like cardio and stuff that's why a lot
of people like they
they clown clown like zumba and [ __ ]
like that but that [ __ ] gets people off
the couch man because it doesn't look
scary to them you know but it gets them
moving and it gets some sweating and
gets them motivated and then eventually
like they might lose a little bit weight
but then they graduate to something a
little bit harder what happened over
here zumba over here in north when i
first moved when you were in zumba no i
used to go to ymca they used the zumba
for me and my wife before we had the
baby and i was traveling i was
shooting movies or whatever and doing
stand-up at night me and my wife had a
deal on tuesday nights we go to yoga
together
and then we go eat dinner then we go and
watch sunday
that was our deal every week tuesday
nights [ __ ] money [ __ ] stupid comedy
shows it was just me and uh
so we used to do the yoga and then go
into the gym for a half hour
and when we'd walk out
professor alvarado there would be 50
women on the line waiting to go into
yoga
8 o'clock at night
all of them
chubbier than [ __ ]
and that's and every tuesday i saw the
classes growing and growing and growing
they had to take two rooms then they had
to go outside for a while and then i
could see that it fell apart because one
of the chicks a boy and i'm not even
lying to your boyfriend had a taco truck
so he would park out there in front of
zoom but
after zumba and those 60 big little
chubby mexican women would go out there
and [ __ ] those tacos up and [ __ ]
so that was the i'm not kidding you i
wish i was making up a joke
hey i don't know more power to them i
don't know what zumba's heart i did one
zuma class and i was [ __ ] i was dying
you know what they used to do zuma where
target
on victory
when you parked the car in that [ __ ]
soccer field in there yeah oh 80 100
women you would hear one up in the top
and they'd be playing salsa music and
they'd all be dancing you're absolutely
right professor i never looked at it
that way yeah just to get somebody off
the couch just to go to this man and
it's music and they mingle and they eat
cheese and they're moving
a few times the first time i did it i
was like my my hips and core because
they're they're making you like do all
this you know shaking your ass and
twerking and stuff like that so you do
that
i'm not good at twerking you'll get your
little giant fascinating dance for the
boys
like that dude and uh
what was that summer of sam i haven't
seen that one that's what the new one
they made about which which is the one
john lewis in that one yes it's john
leguizamo yes
yes yes well john leguizamo's buddy
a cool ass movie with him it's called
hollow point have you seen that
it knew he plays like a freaking crazy
ass like freaking like killer for the
cartel john leguizamo you got to see it
it's called hollow point it's really
good i was like whoa where are this
man
like i'm going to have a love hate
relationship that's like a chameleon man
he plays all kinds of crazy stuff first
off
he's been around
for a
long time
i could document him to 84 on miami vice
he played calderon's son
on miami vice and they blew him up
tremendous episode
they blew him up but tubbs [ __ ] the
sister
so he had a baby with the sisters so he
came back blew up the sister
and the baby
and they said lee iacocca was in that
episode who do you think you're [ __ ]
dealing with professor some
[ __ ] novice i don't know his
episodes
oh my god
sometimes i kind of get pissed off with
your years thing his first credit was
84.
okay and what was it mixed blood i don't
know what that was then he did a madonna
video
and then his first real thing was miami
vice wow what the [ __ ] do you think
you're dealing with some [ __ ] novice
you think i'm gonna come in here and
drop knowledge i'm professor joey
alvarado kettlebell fox and that's
gordon
see if it's on there see if it's on
youtube just look
uh just put in john leguizamo on miami
i'm sure it is i guarantee it's on there
that's how dog all those first of all
lawrence fishburne
when i see people like lawrence
fishburne phil collins was on my own
[ __ ] that's good everything remember
that one
yeah that was a good that was good he
was really he was really good i remember
that because i was like wow that's phil
collins
i remember the other one a lot of people
i see
john legend
say what you want to say about them
they've been around for 30 [ __ ] years
say what the you know 40 rocky balboa is
40 years old if rocky balboa came out in
1975
it's damn [ __ ] close to or 43 or
something 42 years old wow
that [ __ ] is still making movies
and the movies he's involved in
are always about paper
any of the users should i go deeper into
youtube
yeah click miami vice verb to see if
that's the one
no no that's some [ __ ]
[ __ ] all that you haven't seen [ __ ] yeah
that was people that were into yeah look
at but he does talk about it
it was pretty interesting
hey
it goes way too far back for youtube
that's what it is
i just thought the i remember him as
benny blanco from the bronx
listen man he was uh hey look who who's
that's um zappa guy
yeah frank zapp was on there
[ __ ] yeah zappa guy
there it is right there calderon's
return miami vice calderon's return
right there he was calderon
yeah
he would he played calderon
miami vice was based
on a black dude in new york whose
brother got shot
by a colombian drug dealer called
calderon
they couldn't figure out who he was but
they figured out he was in miami so the
black guy
went to miami to hunt him down
the problem was don johnson had a
partner the partner's name was jimmy
smith and he got blown up in the [ __ ]
trailer jimmy smith was in that [ __ ] too
pilot episode
jimmy smith was in a [ __ ] pilot
episode
he gets blown up crockett comes into the
picture their temporary partners
but then calderon
sends a hit guy
from [ __ ] miami in episode
three or four or five
and he kills the original he has a hit
list
he kills the original chief
who was
the puerto rican and sanchez and sanford
and son
i don't want hector in my house i don't
want no puerto ricans in my house
he was the original captain once they
shot him
bam the mexican moved in with the bad
skin
jimmy almost whatever's next crazy man
that was crazy in the beginning that's
how now think about that
[ __ ] jimmy smits
again
1984
pilot for [ __ ] miami vice
you see him now what sons of anarchy
still rocking shows
still two years ago he was before that
he was on dexter and he comes out in the
star wars movies too yeah it's [ __ ]
crazy i know he went back that far
because you have to respect these guys
they've been around for 30 [ __ ] you
remember what show that i'm going to
test your trivia now
you ready yeah
what show made jimmy smith's famous it
was a tv show
the law show or something exactly yeah
who the [ __ ] you didn't know the name
you gotta [ __ ] think about he's
getting syndication money from three or
four tv shows
nypd blue he was on
but god knows how long you gotta [ __ ]
write in l.a law he was on some other
[ __ ] law show
you know two years of [ __ ] uh
anarchy
two years of dexter that guy's banking
that guy's bad he's 60 something now you
got to respect those guys let me tell
you something i saw john leguizamo on
miami vice
i didn't know what the [ __ ] he was and
all of a sudden comedy came into my life
and somebody said who's you don't know
who john legazon was and i went to a
[ __ ] store and i rented this tape and
i go that's calderon and they're like
what are you talking about well that's
calderon
on miami vice and they're like no
whatever he does this one-man show and i
watched the one-man show and i got
pissed off he called it like spicarama
or the other one he called and i kind of
got pissed off because it was kind of
like my story a little bit he had
elements of my story and i related to
him a little bit
and then i got into comedy
and i don't know nothing from nothing i
was feeling bad about my life i'm like
what am i gonna do i'm gonna end up just
being a drug dealer i can't go back to
bold i don't have anything and i
couldn't figure out i was going to this
open mic
and i tell this story [ __ ] to young
kids i kept going through this open mic
where it was like it was hell professor
it was like that scene in rocky when he
fights for 17
like you went in there and no matter how
you you did
you still left [ __ ] like what was
that
what's going on in my life
and i went in there one night because it
went from
11 to 4 in the morning the open mic
that just be drunks in there people
smoking cigarettes and [ __ ] fat
chicks that were hookers giving hand
jobs in the corner [ __ ] disgusting
disgusting but they ran this open mic
and there'd be 30 comics there yeah old
triple n
and i went in there one night dog and
they go no there's no comedy tonight
lego zombo is on stage
and that's when i got it i go it doesn't
really matter you have to be in these
places to get good yeah yeah yeah you
know that's the [ __ ] moral of the
story you know
and then i kind of liked him and then he
did he got a show on fox when fox first
started
it was like uh america's most wanted and
the show with [ __ ] uh the chick from
sons of anarchy and the shoe store and
all that stuff you know uh less than
marriage
with children but you do remember there
was a little show on for a few years
with john legend not for a few years for
six episodes called
hit it john leguizamo comedy show on fox
house of bugging okay and house of
bugging then like four or five he's like
he said on google he just like
hey joey
okay so he
got a deal
because there used to be this latino
tour group in new york
and
fox said uh there was a latino tour here
in l.a the mexicans
so fox was taking gambles they took a
gamble with those guys and they put out
a show and then
like ozamo they gave him a six-episode
sketch show called house of bugging
if they did 30 sketches
five of them were [ __ ] hilarious
but he did one put in john leguizamo
house of bugging
it had its moments you know who one of
the sketch characters was
you're going to see right now what the
[ __ ] is his name
the dude that's in the house the dude
that's in the porno movie
that he was the ho they go he was the
dude that uh they go right there the
third one see that one what's his name
that looks like what's going on
is that him yeah
growing keeps growing keep scrolling
keeps growing
chicago militant house of bugging proud
of county
all right that one learning to vogue
learning to vogue right there right
there right in front of you that's john
leguizamo
[ __ ]
if this is the episode you see you don't
know about this [ __ ] professor i don't i
remember this one
are you
tired in your life and i know how to
respond right
is your life void of food
[Music]
this is john leguizamo six episodes on
sunday nights
on
some more fox balls but
be high and sick
i don't want to get
lost
dude joey does have to be every morning
when he comes to the [ __ ]
to the gym
the gerbil
the gerbils
[Music]
i can see why
when the black chick started dancing and
they're like
today
[Music]
this was fox in the beginning like in
this was fox was this before in living
color or after 93 94.
um that's what i'm thinking
this was crazy that was kind of funny
man so that's why when you see john
leguizamo now you're like
what the [ __ ] this guy's been around
95. you got these he's done a lot he was
in spawn that movie spun he was in
carlito's way
he's in a lot of [ __ ] he did this thing
where he's talking about
his roles
i don't know if it was on hbo i don't
know why i saw it
but he talked about carlito's way how
his first scene when al pacino
the first scene he went up the aisle
like that now said cut
and he goes what the [ __ ] is that
john and john didn't know you know just
you know [ __ ] that happens on the set
which was really interesting because he
was like that though um al pacino wasn't
he he was like not sure he would like
get on people and like and kind of bring
it out of them or some [ __ ] like that i
heard i've heard stories about that
aya did this movie the movie i stopped
snorting coke for
this was a 21 day shoot in a row and it
ended on thanksgiving
but
the movie was 100 a day
but it was all the people that were in
this movie like
the guy that's in the fighter the father
jack
mcgee was in it
we did the table read together like
before they even had financing for the
movie and i knew i liked the movie
i knew i could curse i knew i could be
me it was about an a
meeting that got robbed in studio city
in the 70s they robbed the bank and took
over the meeting until the cops got
there and they beat some of the people
and [ __ ]
and this meeting got into a butt to make
a long story short there was an old guy
in this movie
and he was interesting as [ __ ] guys his
wife had died
he was 72.
he still worked
he [ __ ] hated because he did like two
movies of george clooney and he hated
them
but that's not [ __ ] acting he's
looking at the floor what the [ __ ] are
you looking at you know he was one of
these guys that had worked theater with
uh his resume was brilliant but he was
in dog day afternoon
he goes in those days they just called
you at home i knew the casting people he
was in dog day afternoon but he's the
guy
that grabs pacino by the face and says
how'd you get this scar tough guy eden
[ __ ] it was just 30 [ __ ] years ago
that wasn't um scarface yeah he was that
guy he was that old guy in the room
there was an old guy and a chubby guy he
was the winner guy
so he says that
something happened
that guy that gave him that movie had
put him in something else maybe it was
dog day afternoon he had put him in
something else
so he gets there and he goes you know i
walk in there he goes pacino script
looks like it's gone through a [ __ ]
shredder
you know
looks like it's gone through a [ __ ]
shredder he goes he's gone through that
script he's written this is how you know
this [ __ ] is bad to the bomb
he goes he why because he walks in
oh no he walks in and there's a dude
sitting there
and then he he practices the scene he
goes do the scene real quick and that's
when he goes up to him
and he holds the knife to the guy's face
and he goes how'd you get that scar on
your face tough guy eating [ __ ]
and the guy goes cut and all of a sudden
he goes can i see you for a second john
he goes listen
one hour walks in here do not put that
[ __ ] knife in his face okay
that's the [ __ ] movie
you [ __ ] with that we're done please
don't put the knife in his face he goes
not two seconds later pacino walks and
he goes let's do this
he al pacino sits down they focus the
camera they say action he goes he grabs
uh pacino like he just grabbed him a
little bit and he from the knife was
over here and he goes how'd you get that
scar on your face tough guy eating [ __ ]
and he goes john
sell the [ __ ] scene do something with
that [ __ ] knife
and he said the director [ __ ] was
like and he got
pacino wanted him to put the knife in
his face and work him over a little bit
do something with that knife move show
the camera that you want the intimate
you know
so yeah pacino probably does get on you
that's the only story i've ever heard
about him that's it i never heard
nothing i think i've read other stories
like that he gets on people like that
i'm gonna say he kind of like directs a
little bit
he's the pride man he knows he knows
what's up
i would get intimidated
around the guy like him if i heard he
had a reputation i would too like i did
that stupid movie and when i did it and
my scene was with alec ball
some movie that came out recently with
warren beatty
bro i think that you don't even see me
in the [ __ ] movie if they send me a
wrist i think the movie bombed at the
box office nobody knows who that dude is
30 [ __ ] years later that's the worst
and they do a biography about somebody
that nobody knows
if the guy dies do the biography a week
later don't do it 30 [ __ ] years later
nobody knows who the [ __ ] guy is
you're reselling it to me what the [ __ ]
is this it takes a while to get pictures
you know what the [ __ ]
so i don't think the movie did warren
bailey plays that hotel dude that was a
millionaire lived in a hotel in vegas
bugsy no no no no not a gangster
he was a a plane guy too he wrote he
drove a plane around the world or some
[ __ ] and he lived on the top floor and
the mob wanted them out
so that's a [ __ ] great cast i only
saw alec baldwin but when i went on that
set the first day
i was prepared for alec ball
like that's one of the first times i had
to prepare for somebody
and it bugged me but someone he would
stand me down i'd stare him down
and i would always [ __ ] stare him
down to the end so he took his eyes off
me and said you know something about his
wife or something you know
but
uh
i can't imagine like i heard jennifer
aniston's a [ __ ] nightmare really
that's what i heard i don't know how
true it is she looks very sweet
i don't want to do that i'm too old to
do that [ __ ] i'm too old for that [ __ ]
i was surprised how nice adam sandler
was i got really lucky man
i never worked with nobody
i'm lying to you i did the tv show which
i hated the [ __ ] director ego
[ __ ] and i did a commercial one
time
that the guy yelled at me and i yelled
back at him because they had [ __ ] up
it wasn't me they had [ __ ] up it
wasn't me i'm a [ __ ] professional i
could stop a car on the [ __ ] dime
this motherfucker's telling me stop the
car i'm stopping the car but they're a
break they disconnected the brakes when
they put the lights in
i almost went up the [ __ ] pier in
long beach
how are you supposed to stop it
putting the brake on the emergency brake
they disconnected both of them it was a
[ __ ] nightmare either interns had to
hold the [ __ ] thing and push it back
and [ __ ] then they had to connect it the
guy thought it was me
you got to stick up for yourself on
those sets too
i heard that there was [ __ ] something
when they were shooting down nebraska
director went off on him yeah johnny
depp you went off on johnny depp no he
went off on a cast dude
on the set
yeah nobody no bro i tell you i was
thinking about something crazy today
me and lee was talking about when people
do multiple things
and how you get greedy sometimes and you
[ __ ] up you know and because it's the
law diminishing returns
i got a role and otherwise this
and i was really excited about it but
what did i do what do you think i did i
had two days on the set with all these
guys
what do you think i did i booked the
comedy weekend
jesus [ __ ] christ
i get there and they go no you're going
to shoot wednesday and thursday
wednesday maybe all day thursday just a
morning shot
at a barbecue you're out of there by 12.
i said perfect wednesday night i'll
stress out
maybe not they said it's a full day if i
go on at six
maybe i'll be out of there by six
i [ __ ] get on this set
first [ __ ] eight hours i'm ripping
this thing apart but it's at the narrow
movie bro
he shoots from every angle they got tons
of money you know what i'm saying so
they'll shoot shoot it from over there
shoot it from over there shoot it from
nine o'clock
shoot it from two o'clock behind them
you're like what the [ __ ]
i can't even say this line anymore i'm
so sick of it
and then we had to turn the cameras
around
and do you know all i had to say was one
line for two hours let's say the [ __ ]
line guys
because all i can do is the line
don't don't don't put me through this i
couldn't say the line that night and i
was studying it can you imagine 12 years
later i don't know what the [ __ ] the
line was
i barely got it so some of these actors
can do that
they could recite lines do you know who
michael dudakoff is the american ninja
no you don't have american ninjas you've
never seen that movie the american ninja
no he was this white guy michael dudakov
he was like hegan's best friend man he
used to hang out with higgin all the
time and he used to bring him to the
machado academy back in the day but i
remember him from a movie with tom hanks
called bachelor party me too don't tell
me you've seen he remembered his friend
though the white guy with the blonde
hair and when when they go pick him up
he's he's a waiter
and then the the lady is like oh what's
on the menu he's like oh this one has
cheese but cheese gives me weakness and
all that stuff like that you don't
remember that i gotta see it anyway he
he he acted that whole scene out for me
one day and i just i if florida was so
funny because like it was such an old
movie that he remembered those lines
like from 20 years later like perfect it
was hilarious
so i thought you would yes
i'm in a hotel room by myself
and the longest yard comes on or um
i turn the tv like i'm watching comedy
essential when i leave
about three months ago i came back and
the longest yard was on i was in the
bathroom
the lions came back to me
but i don't remember that after that
spider-man i kind of remember
what spider-man were you in two
you know i kind of remember that i don't
remember a lot of that [ __ ] especially
the last three four years or
a lot of that shit's kind of like just
the outstanding [ __ ] i remember that's
crazy
but you remember the important [ __ ] man
because you have like 10 000 stores man
i have a story about everything
doug it's crazy isn't it it's [ __ ]
crazy doug
is it is it easier to act now that you
lost weight is it like because acting it
can be taxing if you're up for
those 12-hour days
the toughest thing i did was weighing
350 pounds
in new mexico
for the longest shot first off the first
day i got there like we got to talk to
you
we need to do oxygen therapy
what is that that's when
a little [ __ ] uh
assistant at the university follows you
around with an oxygen tank
and you basically have a hose in your
mouth
for you you had it you had to walk
around like the first three days
everybody else is running sprints and i
just walked
they just said come down and walk get
acclimated because it's high
at that time listen at that time i
hadn't done anything
in 1995
i had exercised
in probably five years like and i lived
across the street from the ymca
that's why i ballooned all that weight
i went to there was an american jiu
jitsu academy on the corner of highland
and sunset
i went there for about two months i
thought i would die every time he was he
had me doing roles he was a russian dude
he was really a russian gangster he
closed that school went to glendale or
something
but that was the last time i had
exercise after that i said [ __ ]
exercising
so when i got that movie i remember
having to bend over and trying to get
into the football position
it was a [ __ ] nightmare
like that when i got the movie the first
day i was happy but i'm like it's on now
i got to do something i wasn't walking
upstairs in those days i had an elevator
i wasn't doing dick
so the first day i went down i put the
football suit on i tried to run
and i'm like oh [ __ ] and they sat me
down took i was pale and [ __ ] they took
my blood pressure and they said listen
just do oxygen therapy just walk around
so i would just go down there walk
around for an hour
eat a piece of chicken
walk around for an hour this dude would
just follow me around
after three days they had me do mild
workouts but there was a time bro
that they had to bring a truck in with a
piece of wood that was elevated for me
to bend over and touch my toes
tomorrow i could touch my toes ten times
that's how big i was i couldn't even
touch my toes they had to put like a six
inch a four inch by four inch block
the [ __ ] you use for gardening they have
to put one on top of the other one
that's eight inches
[Music]
wow man
that's awesome i know they want you to
get healthy but they also have a movie
to shoot did they was there anything in
your contract saying like you couldn't
lose weight
no no no no nothing like that i wasn't a
principal like that okay you know it
didn't really [ __ ] matter listen
that's the one movie that they fed you
they didn't want
they wanted no misunderstandings with
the wrestlers and the football players
you know you saw football players
but they were all body doubles for all
those shots there were body doubles you
had to feed those 40 guys yeah yeah so
you had to feed those 40 guys again
professor alvarez you had to feed those
40 guys
i'm not like dalip daley would eat a
dozen eggs bro
with a loaf of toast the guy that
weighed the guy with seven feet that's a
gigantic guy yeah you know what do you
think he eats for breakfast to stay like
that
you know he would go to bed with 12
hard-boiled eggs he would take a dozen
eggs upstairs hard-boiled he'd eat them
all
wow
all right what do you think that guy
just that guy what do you think he's and
then you had a football team and these
you know there was a food truck on there
when we were in new mexico it was
basically
a spoilage fest
they were blowing money like they were
pregnant because paramount wasn't around
so they hired strippers from albuquerque
and throwing them up and they would they
would walk around with trays
and all day smoothies
cold cuts salami
[ __ ] italian coke cuts ham cheese
provolone protein bars protein drinks
you name it you know everybody wanted
their name on the movie so every day you
get a box or something
every day come on guys gather around we
got a box from nike here take a shirt
take the gatorade this sports drink
every day
everybody wanted their name in those
credits so every day something they were
trying something else on you went home
with something else
it was crazy
but there was never like a [ __ ] low
on food no like i mean they feed you on
those sets that's what a lot of people
like at the gym that work work on sets
and stuff they're like man it's kind of
hard to really it's hard to always give
it away
if you do it everywhere in this town
like joey they'll feed you when you go
to meetings
like they'll like they'll feed they feed
you at lowly office jobs they have full
school [ __ ] out dude because they don't
want you to leave dude if you go you
ever go to porto's and you just see
people in the morning with
box boxes support those that they're
taking to their office yeah and you see
the same people every morning because
boxes just taking them out of this
because the tv show has to get out that
night and they don't care that they
they'll they'll
order in
hundreds of dollars worth of food yeah
right they're gonna have you leave oh
yeah pork those delivers too
a shame how much we were
that when i got to that set let's let's
figure something out when i got to that
set i was probably 390.
shooting that movie i put the last 20 on
because it was just
i was getting i had a little rep
there was one rep for every three
trailers
and as soon as i get there i tell them
to get me an egg sandwich with ham you
know
and not 20 minutes later listen get me a
pastrami sandwich
i was by 10 o'clock i had a pastrami
sandwich in me five days a week you know
what that does to me oh my god
by lunchtime you already got a pastrami
sandwich
and i'm not talking about like a [ __ ]
thin one
and then when my friends would come i'd
get pastrami sandwiches
when my friends would come to the
setting are you hungry i could eat let's
get a pastrami sandwich i get the guy
over make me three pastramis what kind
of what do you put on your pastry is it
just pastrami do you do it like the
jewish way i'm gonna like this type of
[ __ ] down on alvarado street
your namesake
get off make a right and keep going till
you see death you see that park on the
right-hand side
park right there across the street the
[ __ ] neighborhood is so deadly they
close the [ __ ] language at four and
they have been closed what neighborhood
is that alvarado just the neighborhood
is called alvaro there's a park down
there there's a park down there where i
walked with an agent once when i first
signed with aqua there was a young kid
and we i took them to breakfast there
and i go let's take a walk i thought
there was ducks and [ __ ] like that
next thing you know
mexicans are coming up to me going
social security cards
birth certificates
passports we got everything yeah
you want a kilo you want a machine gun i
mean that was like and you walk up and
it's like a regular
spanish neighborhood it really is that's
why you can't believe this deli is there
you sit there and go the jewish deli
yeah
that's my favorite they got the good
bread and they got the good pastrami if
i'm in a bind i need a fix of patroni
there's a place on which set around the
corner from my friend john evans
jewish guy herman i go in there i get
the [ __ ] sandwich
i get the the soup
he makes me a nice spicy mustard and i'm
good to go jack what kind of soup the
mozzie ball soup no i get the slip pea
with the ham and she makes it homemade
he's kidding me or what he's like
[ __ ] 80
and she's like 40 and she's got a
tremendous ass
all three [ __ ] to give her a
stabbing you know how many times i eat
that and i double look at her like she's
a good looking woman and i'm lying to
you guys she's got to be about 55 60.
but you look at her this woman's got ass
for days
she goes to vegas they came to see me in
vegas they were staying at the thing and
also i look up one night and then they
are and i hugged their name and they
took off because he's a degenerate
gambler he loves all that [ __ ]
my pastrami man is a degenerate gambler
i hear the good places the shitty here
like the places that are supposed to be
good i don't mind kansas cantons campus
about the jewish
places the one place i found
ants on my pastrami ralphie
and then
me and lee went to the one place one
night and i didn't i wasn't fond of it
and lee was definitely not fine have you
been to the oinkster that is the
question no where is that oinkster have
you heard of the oyster this is one in
hollywood the first one is an eagle rock
it's owned by like a pretty famous
filipino chef
they make their own pastrami there they
they smoke their own pork pork butts
there and they have like a pastrami
reuben oh my god dude it'll knock you on
your ass man you got to go there with me
one day it's like one of my favorite
places to eat in la the oinkster
so awesome they make their own ketchup
they make their own pickles they make
their own mayonnaise they make belgian
style fries look at lee he's going
through telling you man
now you're filling up a pastrami
sandwich
i don't like homemade ketchup
you'll like you'll like this
well you don't have to put any ketchup
on your pastrami you can just eat the
pastrami sandwich like it is i mean they
put like on the strawberry she put like
a little bit of slaw and uh caramelized
onions on it as well too it's bomb man
well they have a couple different ones
but you we got to go there one day trust
me you'll thank me it's like my favorite
place in the world to eat
the bankster you've lost a lot of weight
lately you had a trained frontal uh a
tournament and you just kept the weight
down tournaments yep i had uh the master
worlds in vegas and then i had the nogia
worlds in san francisco
so that's that's the whole that's the
whole thing with my um that kb strength
and conditioning program
uh i've been working on it for a while
and
i wanted to just put something a little
bit more straightforward because
everybody's knows me as like the kettle
jitsu guy doing like a lot of jiu jitsu
and fighting moves but i mean i i'm a
lot more than that i do like some
straightforward stuff more traditional
style stuff so
this program is is a little less
specific for jiu jitsu but you know like
little less like complicated movements
more basic movements with the emphasis
on different kinds of snatches and stuff
but that's how i lost my weight and i
and it includes the 15 guidelines
so um
that's how i lost the weight how long is
the video my friend it's an eight week
program now so each workout is like an
hour long
so you'll give me monday tuesday
wednesday thursday friday all that what
comes out with workout charts it comes
with all that stuff now no [ __ ] you're
that detailed
man it's for reals
you don't [ __ ] around
so does it go from
beginner level to more intense so the
first week is basically beginning level
for sure you go through the body
movements to get you warmed up for sure
it starts at all like on any of my
videos i start you up with basics and
then it starts gradually getting more
difficult as you progress
all of them until today my favorite warm
up still
is the turkish get up with no way oh
really
that's still
you do five on each side you're [ __ ]
wrecked you're good man because you're
working your whole body wrecked that's
how many people do that body weight
turkish get up
you're [ __ ] wrecked
i can barely stop the second part of it
the first part i enjoy doing
it's the second part that's the real
deal with nothing your arm's twisting my
knees going off from under me
it's a [ __ ] trip you don't want not
even 12 kilogram or no no no no no i
don't have that nothing
sometimes i'll like when i do uh
the jiu jitsu warm up we'll just do like
a body weight turkish get up we'll just
hold our hand up and just go through
each movement all the way up and just
alternate like that
and i mean apparently
two snorts likes it over here
joey two snares two snorts no we were
talking before the show how
you get tolerance going and the sad
thing about me is everything i did like
i sit here with lee sometimes
and i was telling you there was a time i
used to sell micro dot acid
i would sell a hit
i had friends that built the tolerance
up and they'd do a hit and a half for
like yes or a concert
i was eating three of those
[ __ ]
and smoking one at about 11.
once i was tripping on the ass i put one
in the [ __ ] pipe with some reefer and
like [ __ ] smoke it like i always had
high tolerance wow except for alcohol
the only time i had a high tolerance for
alcohol is when you're snorting [ __ ]
coke yeah if i'm snorting i could drink
i could drink with [ __ ] houdini you
line them up jack what about when you're
all shroomed out no no no no no no no no
no
i can't mix those no i was never a
reefer alcohol guy no no either we drink
or we smoke and in my world 98 of the
time
we're gonna smoke
i would drink just
me buckling up to a bar and getting a
drink
is
i mean it's just something that
i never wanted to do
i never wanted to be that person that
that was my life type disorder yeah yeah
just because my mother had a barn i saw
those guys
but uh i was always ashamed that i
couldn't drink the way most people could
i don't like that i can't walk in and
you could go let's go for a beer i don't
have no desire
i don't drink like that anymore ever
every now and then like a nice little
cocktail no but that's the way i've
always been it's the weirdest thing that
that's the way i've
i like drinks for the flavor of it this
half three quarters of [ __ ] i put in my
mouth i was like who could drink this
paint [ __ ] thinner
that's what i wanted to talk to you
about joey you've seen do you eat for
pleasure or do you eat just to like feel
your body
oh both man okay because that that when
you're doing it just to fuel your body
is something that's
it's it's very hard to to to work to
live with it's it's it is extremely man
and i have gained weight since the last
tournament
i'm actually going to compete at light
well like i
i use that kb strength program to lose
like 20 pounds and i competed that
featherweight you have a menu in there
also
uh menu what do you mean like what they
could eat what they can't eat um you
know what man i make it like
since i teach people on a regular basis
like uh people like simplicity
nobody wants to count calories or
anything like that so what i have in
this one is called the 15 guidelines of
rapid fat loss and it's just 15
read them and they're simple and if you
just follow them you don't have to count
calories you don't have to do anything
man because i don't like counting
calories who wants to go at the store go
to the store and then read how many
calories you have and then like add it
up and calculate nobody wants to do that
i do whatever you do i can't stand you i
have a thing why fitness pal doctor yeah
people use that stuff i don't i don't
like it most people are lazy man people
i know they're wrong sometimes
sometimes i put my breakfast lunch and i
forget to put my dinner i forget to put
that snack at night
but pretty much professor makes me stay
responsible yeah you know like if it
works for you i'm not saying it's wrong
but like i try to make it as simple as
possible on this program the 15 if you
follow the 15 guidelines like for
instance
i switched only
chicken and fish in turkey you know for
two months that's all i ate like you're
eating if you eat leaner meats man
you're going to feel so much different
than when you eat like
a cardio solid taco as opposed to a
chicken taco or something like that you
know like the meat's easier to digest
you feel lighter you trust me you lose
weight
um keep the portion your meal is about
the size of your hand simple you know
drink a lot of water uh eliminate sugar
stuff like that you know those are part
of the 15 gallons if you just follow
those you don't have to count calories
or anything and you just follow the
workouts
and you stay disciplined then you can do
it you know i have this one girl in um
hawaii that's been following the program
i actually like gave her the 15
guidelines before i had i even did the
downloads and everything and i was just
kind of like coaching her
like through facebook and text messages
and stuff like that and dude this girl
got jacked man and she's just like man i
feel better on the mat you know she's
she can even see her stomach muscles
it's hard for hard for women to get
those stomach muscles you know
but she's totally stoked about it you
know my shit's making a comeback do it
man i'll help you man the [ __ ]
12-pack is making a comeback i'm saying
i can start to see ribs and [ __ ] again i
haven't seen ribs in years i saw a
ribbed yeah
and that so you know and that's that's
part of the 15 guidelines too is is take
pictures of yourself oh my gosh like you
know but what it does like
take a picture when you can see your
ribs again and then you're gonna be like
dude i can see my ribs and then keep
keeping it's gonna motivate you to do
more than a couple weeks later then
you're gonna see like
a two pack and then a four-pack
i didn't catch my rib at a [ __ ]
at the house mirror oh what did you
catch that i catch the rib at a [ __ ]
hotel which is real
you know i walk i walk past the mirror
like wow
i have lost weight and also i had no
shirt on like oh wow look at that ribbon
it's making it it's trying hard
it's melting that fat he's got the blood
torch out and i'm saying he's melting
that fat under the heart
but it it you know
every little bit kind of professor
that's what people years ago i said if i
don't have time to go in there one day a
week i'm not going to go in there that
was the lazy way yeah yeah and then a
good [ __ ] dude said to me listen joey
look at the [ __ ] size here
you go to karate one day a week
you'd be helping yourself
and that's what i did i started working
on one day a week the ymca threw me out
the guy said joey you can't even walk in
the treadmill for three minutes
how am i gonna have you in here
because
let me tell you something man
chrissy miller is a comedian from the
comedy store that when i first got out
here she was always at the comedy store
she always really tried really hard to
get on
you know she got a job at the comedy
store she would showcase for mitzi
mitchie just didn't like a comedy but i
thought christy miller was funny all the
guys thought were funny we tried to back
her
when they christy miller this is i was
probably about 360 370.
christy miller came to me and she goes
joey i'm moving to
new york city but i want to give you a
present before you leave
i'm quitting this job so i'm going to
get you a six month membership on this
slide i'll try to get you a year she's
like you need to start going to the gym
i met you when you got here and you put
on a lot of weight
it was the gold's gym on gower
which if you know anything about
anything about gyms
that's the number two gay gym
the number one is the one in santa
monica don't walk in there that's the
number one gay gym that's the number one
engagement supposedly this is what you
hear are you considered a bear do you
know i have no idea i don't ask
questions you understand me but let me
tell you guys something i would go in
there at night because i was ashamed
you know what i'm saying like they were
going there with a sweatshirt yeah
in those days i wouldn't even do cardio
i would bench press i didn't know what i
was doing i was i was still thinking i
was in high school
i was bench pressed and i wasn't doing
all that [ __ ] but you know what man
and i could say a lot of [ __ ] and be an
[ __ ] but
those gay guys were really good to me
man and i got to be honest he was like a
man
nobody ever said nothing to me i don't
lie
they would all say you okay i'm gonna be
over there i see your face is a little
red
maybe you should walk around
the one guy brought me water one night
there was no cosby filling it
that experience at that gym always
changed my mind it always stuck with me
how
i didn't know what to expect
you know i had heard about the other gym
on santa monica that they gave him a
friend of mine he wasn't really a friend
some dude said he went in there at a
party and he went in there
while he was pissing some guy pissed
right next to him and
they don't have this the thing in
between
so the guy rubbed up against him and he
[ __ ] creeped that you know what are
you doing yeah you're [ __ ] he's a
homophobe yeah he was a homophobe so but
the place is kind of weird not and i've
heard of him dude
i heard it from gay dudes even gay dude
it's a little
too much in there because people just
hang out in the bathroom honestly
it doesn't bother me i mean i have a lot
of gay friends no me too
there's a dog park i go to in haunted
park herman dog park i have a bunch of
gay friends over there man and they they
they talk like guys we talk about women
they talk about guys like then
it just cracks me up like they're
talking about the the postman i hope the
postman came in and i saw and she
started fantasizing and i was i was like
damn eric i just started cracking up you
[ __ ] are [ __ ] funny dude you
know where's tony better than lisa yeah
you know where they're sitting there
[ __ ] up tonight
it's monday morning people it's a new
week it's a new year get off your [ __ ]
it's gonna be all right totally better
[ __ ]
let me give some shout outs real quick
to my main men michael fernandez
veto
borderline human my girl cleo i love you
keep doing what you're doing you [ __ ]
savage
barry o'sullivan
push overlord
sorrow my main man my other main man
kern michael and the man of the hour the
one by
one podcast always in the house and
since i got you here and it's a new year
let me tell you something right you're
walking around with those [ __ ]
underwear
since god knows what it's a new year
listen it's time for you to get those
skidmark underwears with the yellow
stained by your nut sack then you wonder
why nobody wants to date you and why
your girl won't sleep over because
you're a filthy [ __ ] animal well
listen uncle joey's gonna hook you up
all right it's that time of the year you
want to be walking around with new
underwears
new shoes to step nice you want a new
bathroom rug
so you can [ __ ] step out of the
shower into pleasantries make sure it's
white so it's a new head for you you
know what i'm saying i'm just trying to
help you out [ __ ] but you always
want to have clean underwear from the
ages of 20 to about 38 i was a disgusto
i never wore underwear i walked around
like big balls of bangs side to side i
used to go commando [ __ ] commando
because i'd rather save on underwear and
snort next to grandma coke
and if i have underwear
anyway picture world we're putting on a
new pair of underwear isn't just fresh
you're stepping into a better day this
is what i'm talking about think about it
underwear is the first thing you put on
and the last thing you take off why
would you settle for anything less than
the best feeling underwear on the planet
i'm gonna tell you why
me unders focuses on producing the most
comfortable underwear you've ever
experienced my friends at me underneath
send me a few pairs and they're [ __ ]
tremendous i wear them for jiu jitsu i
told you a thousand times it keeps my
nutsack dry
no [ __ ] moisture in there you know
why because they got a material made
mold off the most comfortable
best feeling undies you've ever had that
modal is a special fabric made with the
best in class raw materials and are
scientifically proven to be three times
softer than cotton okay and for a
limited time only
everyone in my audience gets 20 off
their first order but you got to go on
our special url
meundies.com
joey right now 20 off your first order
with the undies better day guarantee you
have nothing to lose who got
don't wait any longer go to meundies.com
right now
slash joey and get 20 off your first
order that's meundies.com
slash joey
how you like me now i'm in the mix it's
19. i defend and i got the fix with the
chicken and the quota got the bacon soda
make the water boil workers are loyal oh
[ __ ] little old school [ __ ] ice cube
for you just just to spruce it up lee
sitting there all scared at least
looking at you right now like the grim
reaper lee's like listen i want to go
hang out with joey alvarado but he'll
kill me he's going to make me do
push-ups and sit-ups i can't handle that
stuff
man i'm sweating i'm jewish look at his
face he's got panic
just looking at you he's thinking his
mind doesn't know what to do right now
i've seen his facebook videos i i like
them it's it's fun man it's i make the
workout fun you'll never be bored the
reason why i like kettlebells it sounds
silly but when i've always been chubby
and when
i used to see people who had their
shirts they were all soaked and sweat
and you can see it i always wanted to do
that i could never make it happen
and [ __ ] kettlebells
my shirt's all i'm making i'll tell you
what you run to glendale you're sure to
be wet
let's get those roller skates and
rollerskate to glendale i'll see you
tomorrow [ __ ] dreads six pounds
lighter cheeseburgers are the last thing
on your mind dude i'm saying after my
class you'll be drenched for sure today
was a weird day professor joey what
happened you know
20 years ago man
you never understand people
that have children
when you don't have children you go what
the [ __ ] are you talking about like get
the [ __ ] out of here i got a dog i got a
cat yeah
it's so weird that today was the
weirdest day i've had in a long [ __ ]
time
like it was just
i woke up last night in the middle of
the night like i can't believe this
little [ __ ] savage
has been walking around for four years
and how everything just changed
like that just changed
it's a it's a miracle that you can even
have babies
i don't even know if i can i'm 45 i've
never knocked up a girl i've never had
an accident like everybody has these
accidents and stuff like that never so i
don't even know if i could have knocked
up one girl but i never had any [ __ ]
accents
you know so no i knew for a long time my
sperm was poisoned then
i was telling you i was doing a [ __ ]
grammar blow
and two snorts mm-hmm just that savagery
that's crazy that was you know you know
me i'm a [ __ ] animal i want the best
of the best i hunted down the best and
told the guy listen i know where you get
it from this is his name
if you want me to go down there and get
it i'll go down there and get it but
don't do that you live around the corner
i'll be here every [ __ ] night give it
to me the way he gives a date
the guy said fine
he couldn't believe it he goes i can't
believe you called me an hour later what
do you do with this [ __ ] i said i snort
he goes you know you [ __ ] tolerances
jesus he didn't do it but he saw the
people that were doing it
and he goes i cut it they don't call me
for two days what the [ __ ] do you do
with it damn
it's like those stars man you eat those
stars like it's going out of style too
and you have a you have like
a high tolerance i have a high tolerance
stars i'm getting the high tolerance to
these tk what are we eating
look at what are they like is it gum
look what is look at look at lee's poor
face look he's sitting there going
jesus christ is paula home tonight
she's home tonight yeah she's at your
house yes oh you're done yeah
60 minute activation
250 milligrams we split one of those
we each had one yeah we each had one and
then we split one of the [ __ ] taffy
toms yeah we had like six thousand five
hundred milligrams i don't know how you
guys are still functioning right yeah
bro we're in training
you train kettlebells we train thcs
stars we train combat [ __ ] stars here
if we get captured and they give us
stars we outlive it yeah but do you
train kettle [ __ ]
no i haven't done that
changed all that [ __ ]
but it's really funny to see her
this little [ __ ] girl who i never
thought i'd get a second chance at
since the minute i walked in yesterday
from the casino she was talking to me
about a party and we talked about it
and she was real cool i thought she was
gonna have a nervous breakdown she was
dynamite and then today the mother had
to leave with felicia to go set up at
the park and i stayed with her from 10
to i walked her over and it was just
[ __ ] tremendous man i'm talking to
this little [ __ ] girl about
a party i tried to show a rocky she
don't give a [ __ ] about it
she's like get the [ __ ] out of here i'm
not watching this [ __ ] dude
punch this dude in the gym and this ugly
chick
and uh i walked her over and just the
conversation we had on the way over it's
like
i saw this little [ __ ] girl
i couldn't even talk and now she's
talking to you about the craziest [ __ ]
i tried to sing tonight she told me no
no no no no daddy no no no singing
her grandfather called and tried to sing
a happy birthday she told to no no no no
please don't
some of the kids wanted to play with her
she said no no no no leave me alone
so some kids are trying to tell me yeah
yeah no no she's by the book jack
she's like by the [ __ ] book joe
alvarado and then there's her party but
just like you she ran over to the other
party and just started talking to some
other people
and started playing with the tree
she was like never after a party listen
those people made a mistake they set up
like 20 minutes before we did and i got
there a little bit too early
at first we lost my daughter she was
over there mingling at the party singing
happy birthday i'm like what the [ __ ]
are you doing
[Music]
but you know you've got your blood in
her man you know who's the happiest
today my wife my wife knocked it out of
the [ __ ] park she [ __ ] made those
cupcakes
she [ __ ] is it fun party
you know what it was a fun party it was
just fun to see
the different combination of people that
showed up
and just speaking of kettlebells and
parks
like that park i think is a great park
to work out for the kettlebell class you
know what bro they watch that part oh
yeah they want snap on like a
[ __ ] because i know a guy who
teaches they gotta teach us karate at
that part
teaches at my daughter's school
on saturdays and he was telling somebody
one day that
he's got to be off that thing by a
certain time oh yeah
yeah so they watch it if you go in there
if you go in there at night that place
is hard to even hang out
there's cops back there there's a
security school there's a school
and they have security did you see that
you can't put bumper houses
do you see the signs you're not allowed
to put those [ __ ] floaty houses oh
yeah yeah
like they're not responsible
they don't want those type of parties
but it's first comes first serve or
something yeah together table we got
three tables pretty much like any part
you have to go like early in the morning
and
camp out there to keep get the table it
was very nice it was very low-key it was
just family
george came that's cool man john abbott
you know
that's beautiful you have a nice little
family that's cool they got kids man you
know and uh
there's two parks there it was the best
thing about the thing was my daughter
was excited
but i don't think she was excited of
knowing how excited my wife was so my
wife made it work my wife knocked it out
of the [ __ ] park man
my wife became a different [ __ ]
person the last four years
and that's been pretty interesting to
see you know
again it's very hard to explain this to
a single guy i'd be looking at me right
now going shut the [ __ ] up man i love
kids man and it's man it
i see what people go through with kids
and stuff like wow man that's a lot of
responsibility but i see how it changes
people's life all the time being married
is [ __ ] very hard
i can imagine everything is one of the
hardest things you'll ever [ __ ] hear
about tough man that's why i've never
gotten married man something i take
seriously when i was young i got married
and i didn't know what the game was i
didn't know what the rules were i didn't
know i thought marriage was you [ __ ]
somebody that did laundry and cook and
you worked
that's it you came home when you wanted
to that's not marriage and that's why it
didn't work
now i gotta work on my marriage like i
really work on my marriage because i
know what keeps it together i gotta work
i don't wanna hear no [ __ ] barry's just
work man you know you gotta work i gotta
do my thing i gotta do the podcast i
gotta do this i gotta do that
but
i have to uh
do my thing if i'm not doing my thing
i'm picking up an envelope i'm home with
my wife
that's the only rule that i got that's
not even my wife's rule it's just me on
a gentleman
you got to be home i was talking to
one of the kids parents today and he was
saying that he was a teamster
and i go do you work a lot and he goes i
work four days a week
i go your choice and he goes
my choice because if i work more now
i'll lose my family
because it's 16 hour days yeah wow you
know you work 5 16 hour days
but if your family needs to eat you know
what i'm saying you got to do what you
got to do
i guess his wife makes money he makes
little money and you meet in the middle
you don't go over your
over your monthly [ __ ] stipend and
that's uh
that's how you make it work man
you really gotta watch everything
today's economy you got to watch
everything
you always got to put a little something
away you know sure it's ten dollars a
[ __ ] week
which i never believed until [ __ ]
five years ago
i never had money to put away were you
[ __ ] crazy i put money in the bank
for a week [ __ ]
i'm the same way there was money in the
bank for a week and [ __ ]
i would look at it and go you're still
there
oh [ __ ] i'll make this happen and [ __ ]
this motherfucker's been laying around
for a week i gotta spend this [ __ ]
grand
you know but now you have a child that
has responsibilities now probably the
amount of money
that i used to have in my bank account
it's like my wife said you would hit me
up every day for a 20 and look at your
account you have like 22 bucks
when i stopped doing drugs
that money was amazing what i would
happen after three weeks i would go oh
my god where did this money come from
yeah because you're not doing [ __ ]
drugs no more mm-hmm
you're not doing [ __ ] drugs [ __ ] yeah
same thing with alcohol man you know i
know a lot of people that go out on the
weekend every weekend just pounding and
pounding and pounding around you could
blow a few hundred bucks on drinking
every week and easy
it's an expensive proposition
to [ __ ] drink
it really is if you look at it again in
today's economy
you know the last time i paid for a
drink was [ __ ] 20 years ago and i
became a comedian
i don't i haven't paid for a drink on
the plane i get the tickets
whatever i don't know another
[ __ ]
but i know people who those drinks are
12 bucks yeah easy those fancy [ __ ]
drinks they ain't [ __ ] around dawg
your wife drinks more out of this more
at a club two minutes are you serious
yeah hell yeah
oh yeah look at the club isn't like a
bottle of hundreds of dollars yeah but
even just like a mixed drink itself of
like 16 15 16 bucks come on then you're
thinking about the tip too you get the
tip
[ __ ] that
what'd you do you did some blow before
you came in here no man stop stepping
into that microphone it's like you're
sniffing
i'm not sniffing on it
i think that like i'm allergic to some
just certain not allergic but like
certain types of weed like it gives me
like makes my nose dry it makes me want
to sneeze i'll do another bunker i'm
gonna put you in a different [ __ ]
plan i got some anti-allergy medical
marijuana you'll stop itching if you got
vd
you'll leak audi it's tremendous no but
i really uh
all jokes aside i really
it meant the world to me to do this
today and it was nice that lee showed up
steve simone showed up felipe sparzer
showed up
which was nice he showed up with his kid
i got to talk to him i never see felipe
his boss
but he's such a mexican philippines he
does all the family things you can
invite felipe there was no vegan food
his son was eating wings too felipe's
bars of one last comic standing
because i know about six years ago great
friend of mine since i first moved here
which is gonna be 20 years january 29th
he was one of the first spanish dudes
that
we [ __ ] got along he introduced me to
willie he introduced me to jeff garcia
he introduced me to [ __ ] jeff garcia is
funny yeah he introduced me to fluffy he
introduced me to martin moreno and mark
moreno had a room
down in some [ __ ] hellhole
you know he introduced me a lot of those
guys he'd say call him up for
you know i remember i go back with
gabriel when he ran the casino over here
the bicycle club off the 710 gabriel
used to book thursday nights for 42
dollars or 36 dollars and you couldn't
get paid till friday
so in hollywood traffic you had to drive
back down there on friday to get your
[ __ ] 40 paycheck i used to drive me
[ __ ] bananas
yeah bananas they wouldn't mail it out
to you
ass give me that [ __ ] cash i didn't
believe in the mail in those days you
got a check in your hand yes i do sit
tight
you're still on support yeah give me 10
[ __ ] minutes i'm gonna roller skate
there uphill you know what i'm saying
i'll be there
i was one of those dudes dog i'm one of
those [ __ ] first off i would
wait for that
when i was snorting coke professor i
would wait for the mailman
i would be out saying he'd get there at
10 after 12 i'd be at attention filipino
dude i'd talk to him ask him about his
sports betting becks
say what do you got for me i have
nothing for you right there i went to
work
i did this job three weeks so i should
be getting the check i get to the bottom
of this who's got my check well it's
here but we haven't run into it
tell me again is it right there in front
of you what if
what if i go down there with a check and
pay the vig off just give me the [ __ ]
check yeah come down okay
what's the commission i get the [ __ ]
check from my wife and i go down and get
the check why are we waiting with my
money 10 days 15 days i shot the union
is 10 days
if you shoot something for the union i
think it's 10 days 30 days something
weird
but if you shoot something if you shoot
a movie and if you shoot a tv show it's
different
that's what is this like a 10-day
difference look at look at my boy lee
syed
going through deep changes he's thinking
of his life moving to mexico
joining the witness relocation program
looking everything all right little
brother yeah i'm glad i'm
you're what
you can't talk man no no no i'm always
just listening to guys conversation no
it's just uh
i don't even know what the [ __ ] we're
talking about professor what's the story
crazy [ __ ] man
crazy [ __ ] i'm about to head to to the
europeans and portugal man a couple
weeks so
i'll be gone for seven days that's
what's going down and when what do you
got to weigh in at
this this time i'm going to stick out
lightweight man and what's that
lightweight is um
with the ghee you have to weigh in at
168. so before i like for featherweight
the last two tournaments i did a
featherweight which i had to weigh in
like at 154.
but like with no g it's even louder than
that i had to be 149 pounds so i got
down really light but like since you
know professor was gone for two weeks
and i was working on that kb strength
and conditioning program for like a
month
i didn't even i couldn't even work out
man and then i put a lot of weight back
on but i've managed to kind of taper it
off so i'm not walk i used to walk
around like 170 before i did the kb
strength and conditioning program and
this right now i'm rolling over
and i'm 45 bro
so this is 46. you know you know what
what's funny is i just realized how old
i am i was fighting master three
for like the last few years and then
when i registered for this tournament it
kind of it automatically tells you what
what uh class you're in you know and now
i'm master four
45
i i uh i was born in 1971 so
now i've moved up to an older weight
class so i'm going to be fighting you
know i'm alan the savage that old man
blue belt yeah i want to be fighting
spools like that now
from what age to what eight what's this
age
i don't know like 45 someone 45 so
it's like every like four years or
something like that or something like
that because like
it goes like from
29
years old and down that's adult
and then after 29 so when you're 30
that's master one and then every few
years it's like master two master three
stuff like that what's the last age
group man i don't know dude cause like
alan like sometimes he competes in those
terms and they don't even have his his
uh category he's 67 he's like dude
he's like i think he's like 70 years old
and he gets there at six in the morning
no no no he gets there at nine okay
at nine
he pull pulls those dummies out
and he starts making love to him on the
mat you see what he does
you get to there's dummies on the
[ __ ] i see that guy he's over there
eating a bowl of food he's going to get
like his raw oats and berries
it's [ __ ] crazy he gets these dummies
and he's just like this this old guy
allen i mean we call him savage man he
gets his mat these dummies these
grappling dummies and he's just he's
going all in between their legs and just
doing all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
and he'll do that for like at least two
hours before the actual class
and then what he does is he goes to his
phone on youtube you know because he
looks up all these techniques and then
he goes and does him on the dummy
it's crazy man it's crazy
i mean he i mean that's what that's what
he that's what keeps him saying he says
because i mean he's been married to the
you know he's been married and he's
retired
so he leaves the house and he's gone
like he's got his other gym for like six
hours
doesn't he do no g class
yeah man that's i love alan to deathman
but i tell you what
that is like one of the hardest classes
to teach with that guy in there
because like you know kind of when
you're that age you're kind of like
already stuck in your ways you know what
i mean you kind of just want you just do
your own thing he doesn't like when we
do warm-ups he was he don't he doesn't
do the warm-ups with us he just kind of
does his own thing but i'm like alan
listen
in my class you're gonna [ __ ] do
the warm-ups the way we do them together
you know and he'll start he'll do it for
about a few seconds and then he's back
off in his own little world again you
know what i mean
and then oh you know we're talking about
little benny right yeah poor benny
sometimes in that 10 a.m nogi class it's
just him and benny in that class and and
i got to give it to benny man for you
know having so much patience because
alan like his style of jiu jitsu is like
he slaps you in the face and does an arm
bar and you know what i mean he slaps
you in the head and he does all kinds of
because he he does all kinds of dirty
[ __ ] man you know like
he's like 70 years old
dude like he loves like smacking people
and doing he does like crazy [ __ ] man
like and then and then and they're like
professor like i don't know what to do
with allan i'm like old man i've heard
this amazing i don't know what to do
with allen man like
they're like he says hey let's go light
and then he goes hard on you so i don't
know what to do but they don't know how
to react to it because he's older and
they don't want to go hard on him i'm
like
man i don't know man i don't know what
to tell that guy
but he's a great guy loved on to death
but you know he kind of beats through
his own drone
but he paid his dues man so you know
he's 70 years old
no he's a purple belt now no no i know
he was dead when he got it it's it's
just did you see when he was going
through the gauntlet
like that guy one hit him and he was
like no man
he's like nah hit me man he's a good
dude oh he's a great guy that was the
class before new year's yeah he got his
program i'm getting to him now man he's
actually like doing more techniques now
so he gets there at nine and works at
the beginning
he gets there early 70 years old he
rolls up in his car whether it says jj
savage on the license plate
he goes in there he puts his it's like
almost like he um what is it what does
it call whenever you go to football
games and you tailgate he almost
tailgates there man he brings his cooler
of food he's got a whole bench a [ __ ]
tent i've never seen anybody like train
trains it's tremendous
he's got a balance he knows
what his body needs you gotta respect
that
i got him i gotta keep
yeah you got to respect that 70 years
old the muscle
takes a lot to [ __ ] repair at 70.
dude you should have him on the show he
has some crazy i know he does some crazy
ass stories dude
he has a funny story he has like a lot
of funny stories like you man now that i
think about it he has he has a story he
was a fighter he used to fight a lot and
stuff like that he was a boxer and stuff
yeah he's a good guy i used i just read
something a couple weeks ago but
that blew my mind but it made sense
about men today
why their testosterone levels were so
low
and they threw in computers in there and
just
the way uh
pollution
they threw all these factors and they
said that our grandparents
our grandfathers had more testosterone
than we do today
so
it's just really it's like all the nasty
[ __ ] they put in our food and all that
yeah and all that [ __ ] well i mean even
beyond that
doesn't everyone say they want it better
for their kids
most of the time
and maybe they're a little bit nicer
than their parents were and it makes
their kids a little bit weaker
i mean
you know i don't know i don't know how
it works i can't sit here and talk and
say that i know i just read this and it
was just
it's something that i thought about i
thought because the nutrition was off
i really thought because the nutrition's
different
the nutrition levels are different and
what they wanted but i was around the
[ __ ] 70s i remember we were eating
the [ __ ] 70s
it's completely different now oh it's
crazy you know first of all they added
coffee to our world and they had a thing
called coffee drinks don't get me wrong
there was always coffee
but there was never high-powered sugar
drinks
did i see what these people drinking
like frappuccinos and [ __ ] oh
these people are drinking [ __ ] cakes
for breakfast oh man dude i was hooked
you don't know what that does to you you
know what that that sugar spike in the
morning
i know i was addicted to coca-cola's at
six in the morning yeah i'd get up at
six in the morning without your balance
eat without your body even getting
oxygen and before i put water in there i
drink 12 ounces of coca-cola right out
of bed you know what that does to your
blood sugar yeah yeah you know what that
does to you yeah it's so easy to do yes
starbucks is so huge man
and i was like hooked on those
frappuccinos and i was hooked on that
other one over at the coffee bean tea
and leaf and then and then uh five years
like about five years ago i went to
italy
and they gave me a little shot of
espresso and i was like [ __ ] man this
little shot of espresso right here
equals to like two frappuccinos man and
i was like man i'm i'm not going back to
work from the coffee bean the one with
the coffee beans on the bottom of it
that they blend
yeah cherries yes oh my god that thing
is so [ __ ] i was addicted to the
black forest it's the black forest
i was hooked on the big one
it tastes like a black forest cake man
like some cause i was on frappuccinos
and my friend was like no you got to go
to the coffee bean turn me onto that i
was like there i was there like every
[ __ ] every i lived two blocks from it
and i would drive parked so good huh go
in there sit outside i wouldn't tell
nobody i'd drink that black farm that's
good that [ __ ] was packing on calories
you drink one of those at eight in the
morning you're doomed you don't recover
from that your whole day is real
calorically sugar-wise you'll be hungry
100
[ __ ] day you add marijuana to that
[ __ ] you're eating two [ __ ] meals
it's a horror show india's espresso man
you're good to go yeah we talked about
that yeah yeah you looked into it i'm
happy you're an intelligent dude
professor yeah look at that because
because you know like people always say
oh no cuban coffee is stronger it's
strong it'll keep you up for days blah
blah blah and that guy kellen
he he brought me um he was like hey
professor look i brought you so my dad
made a pot of this cuban coffee and it
was delicious it was like thicker and a
little sweeter
i loved it man he was like and he
brought me like about this much of it he
was like don't drink it all because i
was like listen man don't [ __ ] tell
me how to drink coffee i know coffee
because i drink i make my coffee super
strong but then i looked it up and i was
like is cuban coffee stronger than
regular coffee and they're like no it's
the same coffee it's just what makes a
difference is how they whip that sugar
because they make a paste with the sugar
first to give it that that sweetness
and i even googled it on youtube to see
how they do and i was going to try to
make it myself because it's really tasty
but they uh they get the sugar first
and then as the um the coffee is like
percolating on the stove they hit it
with the first three they hit they hit a
few drops and they start with them
whip it all up into it like and then it
turns into like a little paste and then
they add the rest of the coffee in there
but it's it's it's actually a lot of
work man to [ __ ] whip that [ __ ] up
like that man george mazda bar was on
the show a few weeks ago the next day he
came up with becky lee
and he made cuban coffee for my wife and
guess what my wife's been making it in
the morning was it legit legit to quit
though nice man
i gotta have somebody show me that
i really liked it
what about the guy over there that she
said the guy oh that guy cafeto over in
burbank boulevard yeah that's right is
it good i mean is it like magnolia does
he make a good uh cuban coffee you know
what the time i was there i i'd give it
a seven mm-hmm maybe i'll give it
another shot
becky went there a few times so give it
a shot backs in violence yeah it's right
there on uh um i'll check it out man
okay like i mean the one that my boy
kellen brought was very it was very good
that was like the first time i've ever
had a cuban coffee that kills you too
that's got tons of sugar too it does
have a ton of stuff it tastes good
though it tastes good i do like it's a
different sugar it's not like whipped
cream and look at lee you're looking
like jack nicholson this year
look at this here's johnny's chrysler
you're wrecked
you need another starter
listening
no those coffees that that's killed you
know they just had valid stuff that i
didn't really know about i didn't know
there were factors the computers the
phone
the way we sleep because we don't sleep
right because of the computer
it's in the back of your mind there's
something like that the article said
the gmos
there was something else i couldn't
believe it i was in shock but
dude my testosterone must be through the
roof man
you don't shoot nothing extra i don't do
anything man and i at 45 years old
i'm
twice as horny as as i was when i was
25. you think it's the kettlebells that
raise your hand maybe it's just because
i've always like exercised and always
you know
there's probably one point in my life
where i was like a little heavy but i
was never like fat fat you know because
i've always played sports and training
martial arts but maybe i don't know
maybe it could just be your jeans too
like my dad
was like 70 years old and he trains
fighters in mexico he used to wakes up
in the morning at five and runs and
shadow boxes and stuff like that
and he's a little perv too so
you know i don't know could just be the
jeans too you know
who knows man everybody's different you
know
but there's people there's people that
are young that have like uh low
testosterone they have to do
testosterone on therapy you know since
everybody's body is different you know
it didn't work for me man i almost
[ __ ] died
around that level these [ __ ] savages
yeah after my surgery they said go on it
it's good for you you lose weight
thought i blew up what what happened
then i started getting headaches
from the trt [ __ ] headaches yeah you
mean you blew up you gained weight yeah
and then they tried
but i was doing the wrong [ __ ] professor
i was lifting weights and doing deadlift
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] i'm walking around at
340. that's not gonna why shoot
testosterone and walk around at 3 40.
the goal was to go the other way
couldn't stop eating
couldn't stop made you hungrier oh and
ponies and [ __ ] my wife was pregnant
i couldn't even ask her i was getting
horny all [ __ ] day
then i went to dc and i started getting
headaches and they took me to a hospital
and they did the blood test
and they're like bro you got a lot of
red blood cells you got to drain your
blood
and then i was like you got to drain
your head you have to take the blood out
like a pint to make new blood to get
your blood balanced that's what they had
to do that's crazy
it was a [ __ ] nightmare dog so it
didn't work for me it didn't work for me
yeah man your body rejected it yeah
i'm cuban i got too much testosterone as
it is i knocked my wife at 50.
i need to show the testosterone so like
if you didn't have a problem with like
your horniness or anything then why i
don't understand why they were giving
you trt because
the people i was hanging out with at the
time who i still hang out with those
crazy people
all the mma people were like oh you got
to go on testosterone you'll recover a
lot when i first started jujitsu
i was on testosterone it was the worst
thing for me
because when i get on my back
my blood pressure was just sky
my first six months on jiu jitsu i was
on trt and it wasn't doing a [ __ ]
thing for me
it was worse for me i was having panic
attacks and [ __ ] that one like sylvester
stallone does too
because he art didn't just do stereo
because he was like somebody was telling
me he's pretty open about like what he
does to stay like all ripped because
he's jacked man you know
it's either trt or something like that
you know i think that there's
a price to pay somewhere down the line
not for sure man i can't prove it this
guy i don't know what it is
i don't know what it is you know first
off if you look at something like
stallone
the rumors are he's done plastic surgery
everywhere
in fact he had an infection on his thigh
or something
from doing something some sort another i
can't prove this
this is something i just heard so
this is a guy that uh
like i said man i watched rambo two
and i watched the beginning of rambo
first blood part two
that's an interesting one they go to
thailand
and he's stick fighting and yeah temple
and [ __ ]
that's when i had to do [ __ ] i had to do
things to do so i turned it off but
you know who wouldn't want to keep that
image what would you yeah man you know
like he that's kind of something you
associate with sylvester stallone
because like back in the day i mean the
first rocky he wasn't even like jacked
or anything he was jacked he was bigger
he was thick
he wasn't cut up or anything and then
little by each rock he started getting
more and more and then it was like
rocky iii when he was with apollo creed
and cleverland and all that that's when
he started getting like more defined and
then
rocky before rambo was when he started
with the juice yeah but like remember
rocky iv
and dave vlogger man those guys that's
when they were jacked and then i was
like holy [ __ ] and the second rambo
in the first round oh he was pretty
pretty cut up in it but in the second
one i remember because i just i like i
idolized sylvester stallone
the late 80s
and he would go down there and shoot
that's where they would all shoot there
was a kid i knew in
boulder
and his dad owned the gym at yucatan or
something and that's where they would go
and they would meet colombo the
bodybuilder
franco columbus franco colombo
he was uh arnold schwarzenegger's
partner right and franco would shoot
them up with everything they needed and
they come back and shoot and shoot those
[ __ ] movies you know
but i could listen if you watch
if you watch uh uh
sean penn in that close range
he shot something good he shot deck at
the problem
yeah 1985.
sean penn yeah sean penn christopher
walken madonna no madonna had the
soundtrack the movie they pulled the
[ __ ] movies movie advertising so the
movie bombed they thought madonna's
soundtrack would carry the movie but the
movie's a masterpiece yeah it's called
at close close range i never even heard
that it's crazy christopher walken and
sean penny he plays his sister
and it's a [ __ ] we've talked about on
the movie with the first scene second
scene in the movie
as soon as you see sean penn you're like
what the [ __ ] what's going on with his
jacket you could see the veins in his
arms you could see that it was a six
weeks regimen it was just a short little
regimen and he lifted and maybe did
push-ups and he had a trainer and they
taught him how to
put on you know cut perfectly i had a
friend who knew how to do that also he
could work with you for eight weeks give
you hanover or winstro and you look like
a [ __ ]
you didn't look like johnny adonis but
you look like you did something yeah he
knew how to work you out you didn't say
it he didn't shoot you with nothing he
just dropped a little winnie v on you in
those days whatever that is now that's
changed by now
look at lisa what's going on lisa you
keep looking at that [ __ ] professor i
can feel like
he knows about the kettlebell i'm gonna
have to go down there and put it between
my legs and throw up in the air like a
[ __ ]
chef of benihana
oh
yeah you really know what the [ __ ]
you're doing i hope people i hope so i
know that the last time you a lot of
people asked your questions oh yeah man
and you had major league success if
anybody deserve you know what you're
doing man i appreciate it man i put love
in all that but yeah man like
shout out to all the people who
embraced me from the first time i was on
here man i still get emails and i always
send you screenshots i said i sent him
screenshots when people go hey i saw you
on joey's show and
they're super cool man a lot of like
very positive people man i appreciate it
people on this show want to get in shape
people on this show
everybody everybody needs to work out
when you know what to do man everybody
wants to know what the [ __ ] to do
yeah man everybody needs to work out
regardless if i'd love everybody to do
my kettlebell programs but you know it's
not for everybody you know some people
dig other things you know it's okay just
find what you enjoy doing and then stick
with it you know stick with it three
times a week at least you know but
everybody needs to exercise in some form
or another whether it's kettlebells
whether some people like crossfit that's
fine i know people who whose lives have
been changed by crossfit you know they
got into it they knew one guy who was
like a
raging alcoholic man he met some chicks
she did crossfit and his body changed
his lifestyle changed and
more power to him because every time i
was i would see him he was just loaded
he was jacked up on blow he was jacked
up on alcohol all the time
he was and as long as i've known him
he's always been pudgy you know
but like it crossfit it changed his life
you know so um yeah just find something
you enjoy doing and stick with it man
and i've been working with the
kettlebell kings too my sponsors go on
their website
get some kettlebells i'm writing
articles for them and and um we're
trying to share the the kettle jitsu
love together
but yeah man
exercise is very important you know it's
funny because i wanted to put you on for
the last month but i said you know what
let me save him for the first week of
the year
if he inspires one person to get a 10
pound kettle bell
and do turkish get ups the show worked
for one [ __ ] person yeah for sure man
there's there's plenty of people that
bought the program that
that
saw me on this show and and they're
digging the workouts and stuff like that
so in caution caution and i'm telling
you this with caution
i'd love for you
to go to on it right now and get a
kettlebell and i'd love for you to
download
professor's uh tape the kettle jitsu i
love feeding cables
but i also want you to watch and listen
to exactly what he's doing
please do not get a gorilla kettlebell
that weighs 75 pounds and attempt the
[ __ ] that professor is trying to [ __ ]
say to you please don't be that stupid
go buy yourself a secondhand kettlebell
that weighs
you know 12 pounds whatever the [ __ ] the
light one and start with that we don't
want you to get hurt in any shape i
always tell people that helmet they
always you know they always have those i
love most common questions
please go to on it or kettle jitsu kings
or whatever you want to do whatever
works for you guys but do me that favor
pay attention to what you're doing pay
attention to the professor's forms
exactly what he's doing study it
because we don't want you to get hurt
it's not just exactly simple that's why
we always warm up with the body weight
first before we even touch a kettlebell
man
how long is the warm-up before you talk
about um a good like 15 minute warm up
but see like we'll do like a mobility
type of warm-up and basic low-impact
workout and then we'll get into
bodyweight training
because i really feel that you should
master your own body before you master
any kind of like training tool as well
and kettlebell and bodyweight training
they go together so it's not just
kettlebell it's actually kettlebell and
bodyweight so like on this program i do
like a bunch of different burpee
variations you know like
i'm very creative man you know so like
i've developed like a lot of different
burpee variations because
the regular burpee variations it's a
great that's why crossfit people do
everybody does regular birdie but even
just doing that one over and over gets
[ __ ] boring you know so i mean except
me to do a burpee you know i used to i
could show you i could show you a burpee
a variation to do which will suit you
better because you you know you might
not be able to jump up on both feet at
the same time so i have one called the
k-town burpee that's on the cable
strength condition where you come up one
night at a time i actually learned that
from a student of mine anjali korea
anjali korea her uh she's in a band
called koreatown
and she's like a musician and her her
her friends used to drag drag her into a
kettlebell class you know
and she's awesome i love her death but
like she used to do these burpees like
all right burpees and then she'd go down
like one negative leg at a time all lazy
and come up one leg at a time i was like
that's kind of cool i kind of like that
you know so i developed like a burpee
variation called k-town burpees because
like a lot of people who are heavier
can't do a regular burpee so that's one
of the things as a trainer is you always
have to know how to adapt exercises for
people because like like i said like i
have my regulars in kettle jitsu class
and they can do all the the movements
that we do but then i have people trying
it out all the time and everybody's at a
different fitness level so like if i
didn't have ways to adapt for them then
they wouldn't even want to stay in the
class anymore you know so
to be a good trainer you have to be able
to think on your toes really quick you
have to have like a a really deep bag of
tricks
so uh man i can train anybody you know
so yeah for sure
for you too lee where can they go find
all your stuff again perfect kettle
jitsu.com
easy you can find me on
on youtube kettle jitsu instagram kettle
jitsu go to my business page on facebook
kettle jitsu everything but uh if you go
to kettlejitsu.com i have all my
downloads up there and um i'll be
releasing two more downloads this week
um excuse me not weak this year
bodyweight for bjj and kb flow well
that's what kettlebell flows and and
warm-ups for jiu-jitsu and stuff like
that too you're beautiful professor i
appreciate it man i'm i'm a little
disappointed that neither one of you uh
realized that i'm not wearing glasses
right now
did you notice that like in the last one
of my students was like professor you
got to do some of those damn glasses of
yours because i had like these cheap cvs
specials like on the last show that i
did with you and they're all crooked i
don't even realize until you point out
that i got laser eye surgery man how's
it work it's [ __ ] awesome dude i can
drive at night without freaking i could
see your face i could see that beautiful
face of yours that little bite look at
me
oh my god he's [ __ ] done
i love it it's that [ __ ] nice hey i'm
glad i didn't do that start that a full
star with you guys because he was like
no don't worry about it
no i'm good man i told you
listen people i i brought the professor
on
if it inspires you in any way but it's
your year whatever you're doing whether
you're smoking you're gonna you're gonna
quit blow you're gonna quit heroin
you're gonna quit sleeping pills you're
gonna put pain pills
you know what let's do it together but
it's gotta start somewhere this is what
it's all about tonight that wasn't about
for you to get a [ __ ] kettlebell and
hit yourself in the head and kill
yourself
it's more for a new start that's why i
brought you a professor new year news
started
you know what i'm saying do something
and don't forget you [ __ ] savages
over there in the cleveland area uncle
joey's showing up with a big dick and a
warm jacket it starts thursday night
hilarity's
pick wick and whatever the [ __ ] thursday
friday saturday and then the next week
i'm in tempe
at the [ __ ] improv all right so
that's how we're doing it so this
thursday i think it's the 11th or 12th
or something like that
the party starts in cleveland i'll see
you [ __ ] suckers down there let me talk
to you guys about one thing before you
get out of here real quick
okay because you know me i'm no [ __ ]
captain evil here remember one thing
everybody likes this
if you ask the professor sleeping is one
of the most important parts of
everything i even sleep and i still
can't recover that's how old i am
sometimes i go to jiu jitsu i think i'm
gonna go the next day even if i go to
bed early i get eight hours sleep but i
can't sleep but sleeping is very
important you're unique you don't walk
like everybody you don't talk like
everybody you don't sleep like everyone
so why is your mattress one size fits
all because a custom mattress will cost
you five to ten thousand until now uncle
joey delivering the goods introducing
helix sleep where you can buy mattresses
online
customize for you for hundreds of
dollars instead of thousands i'm saving
your guinness right off the [ __ ] bat
all right go to helix.com answer a few
questions based on four key preferences
and the result will be a custom sleep
profile
used to build you the most comfortable
matches you'll ever sleep on your
mattress arrives at your door in about a
week and shipping is [ __ ] greatest
100 free that's how we're rolling and
for couples helix customizes each side
of the mattress
they're always [ __ ] thinking
customers report 30 improvement in
overall sleep you got 100 nights to try
it out and if you don't love it they
pick it up for free and give you 100
[ __ ] refund
no questions asked all right who's
better than uncle joey that's why
everyone from gq magazine to forbe is
talking about healing sleep go to
helixsleep.com
right now slash joey and get fifty
dollars off your order again that's
helixleep.com
joey helixsleep.com
joey you're gonna [ __ ] love it but
for you business owners out there again
we're talking about the beginning of the
year you want to start anew it's a new
year which means you want a fresh start
to your business and a great year starts
with making new great hires all right
but posting your job in one place isn't
enough to find quality candidates if you
want to find the perfect hire you need
to post your job on all the top job
sites and now you can with ziprecruiter
you can jumpstart your hiring in 2017
post your job to 200 plus job sites
including social media networks like
facebook and twitter with one click
who's better than you fine candidates in
any city or industry nationwide look at
the shape of lee oh my god find
candidates in any city or industry
nationwide just post once and watch your
qualified candidates roll into zip
recruited easy to use interface no
juggling emails or calls to your office
people bothering you quality screen
candidates rate them and hire the right
person zip zip zip fast find out today
why zip recruiter has been used by one
million businesses and right now my
listeners you got a business you can
post jobs on zip recruiter for free by
going to ziprecruiter.com
church
c-h-u-r-c-h that zip recruiter
shirts
c-h-u-r-c-h one more time
for free go to ziprecruiter.com
church all right do your thing happy new
year i want to thank zip recruiter i
want to thank helix sleep i want to
thank me on these but most importantly i
want to thank you [ __ ] for
starting the year off with us getting
your [ __ ] together slinging dick and
giving our bubble gum
and that's how we [ __ ] do it if
you're going to be an american this is
for you to do it don't worry who the
captain kirk of the enterprise is you
don't got to worry about trump just
worry about yourself i want to thank
my main [ __ ] professor the king
of swing the master of disaster
kettlebell kings for the kettlebells do
yourself a favor if it wasn't for swings
and [ __ ] with professor i couldn't do a
hip escape right now all right i'll see
you this week in hilarities and next
week in tempe arizona stay black
[ __ ] i love all you [ __ ]
suckers lee kick this meal [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
you